[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سيئه
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم التي تعيش على وقع
ادانات لمقتل والي غرب دارفور خميس بكر
بعد اختطافه من مدينه الجنينه
اما هذه الصور فتردنا من كياز حيث وضعت
جميع القوات الاوكرانيه في حاله هجوم مع
الابقاء على التاهب الدفاعي تزامنا مع شن
القوات الروسيه هجمات مكثفه على اكثر من
محور شرقا وجنوبا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
على وقع ادانات دوليه تتلاحق الاختطاف
وقتل والي غرب دارفور واشنطن تعرب عن خيبه
الامل مما يواصل طرفان نزاع السوداني
القيام به وتتحدث عن فرصه ما زالت متاحه
لعقد محادثات مباشره في جده ومصدر
بالخارجيه السودانيه يكشف للجزيره عن رفض
مبادره الايجاد ويشكك في حياد كينيا
تصعيد روسي في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها لصد
الهجوم المضاد وكياف تعلن وضع جميع قواتها
في حاله هجوم مع تاهب دفاعي وتتحدث عن
استعاده مئه كيلومتر مربع في زبولوجيا ومع
تشديد الناتو على توفير احتياجات اوكرانيا
في الدفاع الجوي مسؤولون امريكيون يتحدثون
عن اتجاه لرفع الحواجز امام عضويه اكياز
في اول زياره لزعيم عربي الى بغداد منذ
تشكيل الحكومه الجديده امير دوله قطر
ورئيس الوزراء العراقي يشهدان توقيع
مذكرات تفاهم واعلان نوايا مشترك في مجال
التنسيق السياسي والتعاون في الاستثمار
والطاقه الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ساني يعلن
عزم دوله قطر الاستثمار بخمسه مليارات
دولار ويؤكد مواصله دعم العراق وشعبه
وضروره تغريب لغه الحوار في المنطقه
والسودان يقول ان المباحثات تناولت
التعاون الامني والمعلوماتي بما يحفظ
الامن المشترك وان المنطقه
توتر متزايد في شبه الجزيره الكوريه سقوط
صاروخين باليستيين اطلقتهما فيونجانج في
المنطقه البحريه الخالصه لليابان طوكيو
تدين الخطوه وسول تعتبرها احتجاجا على
مناوراتها الاخيره مع واشنطن واجتماع امني
رفيع المستوى في اليابان بمشاركه الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا تداعيات اغتيال غرب دارفور
خميس ابي بكر بعد اختطافه عصر الاربعاء من
مدينه الجنينه وما اعقبهم من ادانات
سودانيه ودوليه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
في رايكم ما تداعيات مقتل والي غرد دارفور
على دارفور بالكامل
87% قالوا ان نطاق العنف سيتسع بين مصوت
13%
لصالح تراجع حده المواجهات هذا السؤال
سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم
دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار
الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
خلال لقاء قمه في موسكو روسيا والجزائر
توقعان اعلان شراكه استراتيجيه شامله
وتبون يثني على دعم بوتين لطلب انضمام
الجزائر لمجموعه بريكس
[موسيقى]
اذا مع استمرار نيران الموجهات في عده
مناطق في السودان تتواصل بيانات الشجب
الداخليه والخارجيه لعمليه اغتيال والي
غرب دارفور وقد اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات
الدعم السريع بخطف وقتل الوالي خميس اب
بكر لكن قوات الدعم النفث الاتهام ودعت
الى تحقيق مستقل في احداث الجنينه وبشان
وساطه ايجاد ابلغت الحكومه السودانيه
رفضها رئاسه كينيا للجنه السودان
باعتبارها طرفا غير محيدا في الصراع
الدائر من جانبها قالت الخارجات الامريكيه
ان لدى واشنطن خيبه امل مما يواصل طرفان
نزاع في السودان القيام به لكنها ستواصل
الانخراط مع السعوديه بحثا عن حل لازمه
وقف اطلاق النار
من الخرطوم الى الجنينه بدرفور المشهد
قاتم ومرعب دخل الصراع في السودان شهره
الثالث بتصعيد في الاقتتال الدامي وبنبا
اغتيال والي غرب دارفور اختطف الوالي خميس
ابكر بعد ساعات من ادانته في مقابله
تلفزيونيه ما سماها انتهاكات قوات الدعم
السريع في مدينه الجنينه المحاصره لاحقا
قتل وصور خاطفه جثته المغطاه بالدماء شجبت
جهات داخليه وخارجيه عمليه الاغتيال
المروعه بكل تفاصيلها وتداعياتها الخطيره
المحتمله اتهم الجيش السوداني قوه الدعم
السريع بالوقوف وراء الهجوم الغادر الحد
وصفي بيان البرهان قال انما تقوم به قوات
الدعم السريع من قتل وسلب وترويع في
الجنينه يعكس مدى الفظائع التي تقوم بها
القوات المتمرده ضد الابرياء سرعت القوات
الى النفي وتقديم روايه مغيره لما جرى
محمله للمسؤوليه لمن سمتهم بمنفلتين وبان
الاغتيال يدخل في اطار صراع قبلي دعيه الى
تشكيل لجنه تحقيق مستقله بشان الاحداث
التي وقعت بالولايه وادت الى مقتل الوالي
ومئات المواطنين من جهتها اتهمت الامم
المتحده مباشره قوات الدعم السريع وجاء في
بياني بعثتها في السودان ان افادات مقنعه
لشهود عيان نسبت الاغتيال الى الميليشيا
العربيه وقوات الدعم السريع حتى هذه
اللحظه تشهد الجنين وضعا امنيا وانسانيا
كارثيا وهي جزء من المناطق المنكوبه بسبب
الصراع الدائر منذ ابريل الماضي مع اتساع
رقعه المواجهات تضيق فرص وقف الاقتتال لا
الهدن الهشه عمرت ولا الوسطات الاقليميه
والدوليه نجحت في وضع حد او حتى جدول
زماني لانهاء الماسي التي تد السودان معك
كل يوم اخر من المواجهات المسلحه الوساطه
الافريقيه تصطدم بلاءات تجعل فرص فشلها
اكبر ابلغت الخارجيه السودانيه منظمه
الايجاد رسميا رفضها رئاسه دوله كينيا
للجنه ازمه السودان باعتبارها طرفا غير
محايد لم يدم كثيرا تفاؤل الرئيس الكيني
ويليام روتو الاثنين الماضي في جيبوتي
خلال القمه الحكوميه للتنميه في الشرق
افريقيا ايجاد بنجاح مساعيه لعقد لقاء
مباشر بين طرفي الصراع في السودان من يملك
اوراق ضغط اكثر لجمع المتحاربين حول طاوله
الحوار العصير الان الافارقه ام اللاعبون
الدوليون ام المغيبون في مشهد الوساطات
الى متى هذا النزيف السوداني غير المسبوق
والمعدي بحكم التاريخ والجغرافيا ومفاجات
حسابات السياسه غير الساره
وقد يصدق كلام محلل سياسي جاء فيه انه لن
يتفاوض احد بجديه حتى يشعر بان التوازن
العسكري لم يعد قابلا للتغيير
معنا في الاستوديو مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك نبدا
من تداعيات اغتيال والي غرب دارفور ما
المتوقع
لم تكن مفاجاه لاننا ظللنا على مدى عده
ايام عبر هذه القناه ننبه هو نتحدث عما
يحدث في مدينه الجنينه من تصفيات عرقيه
ومن عنفه ومن قتل وترويع للمواطنين العزه
وقتل على الهويه لقبايل بعينها ولم يحرك
العالم
ساكنا ظل يتفرج على هذه الماساه الانسانيه
الضخمه الموجعه حتى بلغت ذروتها بقتل خميس
ابو بكر والي شرق دارفور بطريقه بشعه على
يد وتدعم السريعه التي اوقفته ثم وثقت
لعمليه اغتياله اعتقاله ابتداء ثم لعمليه
اغتياله
بما سار صدمه كبيره ولكن هذا لم يكن
مستغربا نظرا لما ظل يحدث في هذه المدينه
منذ اكثر من شهر هذه المدينه عزلت عن
العالم
الاتصالات قطعت عن المواطنين المياه
والكهرباء
واخرجت كل المستشفيات عن قطاع الخدمه توفي
فيها الان في موضوع تداعيات هذا الاغتيال
لان الكل يحذر من توسع نطاق الاشتباكات
ربما في دارفور دخول العنصر القبلي على
الخط ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث
والعنصر القبلي لم يكون خارجا المعركه في
الاساس هي معركه بين قوات الدعم السريعه
التي تمثل العنصر العربي في ولايه غرب
دارفور مع قبائل الزرقاء القتل تركز على
قبائل المساليد
والنوبه في في غرب تارفور وبالتالي هذا
الامر يفتح الباب واسعا لصراع اكبر ولربما
لعوده الحرب الى دارفور سيما وان المجلس
الامني يغي الايادي القوات المسلحه
السوداني عن التدخل في دارفور بقرار سابق
وبالتالي فان هذا الامر يحتاج الى من
العالم الى الى نفتح محتاج ايضا من القوات
المسلحه السودانيه لان تقوم بواجبها وان
تسارع الى نجده اهالي ولايه غربي دارفور
في عمومهم وسكان مدينه الجنينه على وجه
الخصوص
كيف وفد المكون العسكري رئيس مجلس السياده
الخارجيه السودانيه
لرئاسه كينيا للجنه الوساطه المنبثقه عن
الايجاد ماذا وراء هذا الرفض باعتقادك رفض
كان متوقعا على اعتبار ان الطرف الكيني في
عمومه والرئيس الكيني على وجه التحديد ليس
محايدا لا يصلح كوسيط في هذه الازمه لانه
معلوم لكل السودانيين فان الرئيس الكيني
يرتبط بعلاقات عمل ضخمه مع قاعده قوات
التمرد حميتي وهو لم يكن محايدا في كل هذه
الازمه حتى تصريحاته كانت عدوانيه وبعيده
عن العرف تنتهك الاعراف الدبلوماسيه
وبالتالي
عليه من الطرف الافريقي هذا اختيار من من
السوداني ابتداء في قمه الايجاده الاخيره
على اعتبار ان ويليام لم يكن اصلا من
البدايه متوازنا في مواقفه بل ان مندوب
قوات الدعم السريع كان مقيما في نفس
الفندق مع
الوفد الكيني ويقال انه حضر معهم وبالتالي
يفترض في الوسيط ان يكون محيدا ان ينطلق
من منصه تمثل المصلحه العامه شديد سيد
المزمل هل هذا الرفض من جانب السودان يعني
ايضا رفض الفكره التي اقترحها ويليام روتو
بجمع
حماتي والبرهان بحوار وجه لوجه الفكره
اصلا لا تخلو من السذاجه على اعتبار ان
هذه هذه الحرب لا تمثل صراعا بين الرجلين
هناك دماء سفكت هناك اعراض انتهكت هناك
منازل احتلت وهجرت ماسي ضخمه جدا الموضوع
اكبر من ان يقتصر او يحل بلقاء بين رجلين
شكرا جزيلا لك مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني
من جوهانسبرج معنا الدكتور ديفيد موني
الخبير في الشؤون الافريقيه ومدير معهد
كونفوشس في جامعه جوهانسبرج دكتور ديفيد
مونيه كيف وجدت هذا الرفض السوداني لرئاسه
كينيا للجنه ازمه السودان التي
خرجت عن قمه الايجاد الاخيره
الوضع في السودان
يزداد سوءا
والمحاولات الاخيره من قبل القياده كينيا
والايجاد من ان يكون هنالك تدخل
جماعي لديها فرصه لكي تجمع الجنرلين ولكي
يناقشا الوضع لكن قد يكون هنالك قضايا
اخرى بالاخذ بنظر الاعتبار مثلا
لان كان هنالك محاولات سابقه من السعوديه
والولايات المتحده لكنهم لم ينجحوا في
تحقيق وقفه اطلاق النار بالتالي الفرص
قليله جدا اذا ما
تدخلت الايجاده لكن القاره الافريقيه ليس
لد امامها خيار اخر فيما عدا ان تحاول ان
تمد ايديها الى
جنرالات يبدو وكان القتال ينتقل الى اطراف
اخرى في غربيه كارفور وايضا لديه تبعات
على اكثر من مليونين شخص في السودان
والذين هم
هذا الخيار الذي وقع على رئيسي كينيا
استفز البرهان والحكومه السودانيه على
اعتبار انهم
يعتبرون ان كينيا طرف في هذا الصراع وهي
تنحاز
لقوات الدعم السريع لماذا وقع الاختيار
الافريقي على كينيا
اعتقد
ان التحدي الذي
تواجهه واجهه الاتحاد الافريقي وخلله عبر
ايجاد في هذه المرحله كان
يركز على ان كل دول الجوار باي طريقه او
باخرى يبدو وكانها تفضل احد طرفي الصراع
ايضا مصر بشكل مشابه تم لومها على انها
تدعم الطرف الاخر في نهايه المطاف الامر
يتعلق بتوازن بين كل تلك الدول مع مصالح
تلك الدول وان يكون هنالك تفكير يتعدى دعم
الطرف الذي يدعمونه في الصراع من اجل
مصلحه السودان ومصلحه المنطقه باكملها
بالتالي اعتقد اننا
نجد سنصل الى ذلك الهدف في نهايه المطاف
لكن الان الجيش السوداني البرهان الخارجيه
السودانيه يرفضون
رئاسه كينيا كيف ست تعامل ليجاد مع هذا
الامر
ايجاد ليس لم امامها اي خيار سوى ان تحاول
ان
تجد طريقه اخرى هي لا يمكنها ان تجبر
الرئيس الكيني اذا ما كان موقفه
ليس مطلوبا ومرحبا به من قبل الاطراف
المتقاتله اعتقد ان الخيار الافضل هو
محاوله ايجاد بديل
اللي دوري القياده لتمثيل الايجاد الامر
سيكون تحديا لكن اعتقد ان ايجاد هي
نفسها هي
المنصه ذات الشرعيه لتلك الدول شكرا لك
الخبير في شؤون الافريقيه ومدير معهد
كونفوشس في جامعه جوهانسبرج ضيفنا من
جوهان شكرا لك
ومن اقليم دارفور يتواصل خروج اللاجئين
باتجاه منطقه ادراكشاديه باعتبار باعداد
كبيره ويقول بعض هؤلاء اللاجئين ان عددا
كبيرا من الفرين من مدينه الجنينه في
ولايه غرب دارفور قتلوا في الطريق مراسلنا
فضل عبد الرزاق رصد وصول اللاجئين
السودانيين الى منطقه ادري
المئات من اللاجئين من السودان من مدينه
الجنينه يفرون الى شات هذا الطابور هو
للقادمين حديثا الى تشاد ومن الواضح انهم
وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه مشيا على الاقدام
استاذنا متى وصلت
الساعه كم لا يتحركن قبل نصف ساعه اربعين
دقيقه كده يا اخر منطقه دخولنا
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على سلامتكم
طبعا
الحدود التشاديه مفتوحه
للاجئين لكن معظمهم حتى بعضهم وصل وهو
حافي
القدمين ليس لديهم اي امكانيات
هؤلاء ايضا قادمين من
الجنينه وواضح ان بعضهم
الجرحى كما تشاهد وين اصبت بالجرح
كنت مشارك في
الاحداث هنا
طبعا عندنا جرعه وعندنا
طريقه عشان نرفع الجراده
هل يعني قبضوا منكم اسرع
كم تقدر
نساء اطفال
والناس الجراح
يبدو ان معظم
المسلحين هم من
الذين وصلوا هنا هم من المسلحين التابعين
لبعض الجهات داخل الجنينه ولكن ايضا
في نساء وفي اطفال
كلهم وصلوا الان الى الجنينه من الجنينه
الى تشاد فضل عبد الرزاق ادري الحدود
التجاديه السودانيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني هنا مليار ان
الجيش الاوكراني منخرط في عمليات هجوميه
ودفاعيه على طول خط التماس مع الجيش
الروسي يترافق ذلك مع تطورات ميدانيه
تتمثل بكثافه القصف الروسي المدفعي والجوي
على مناطق واسعه في دنياتك
تشيل معطيات الميدانيه ان الرد الروسيه
على الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد قد بدا
بالفعل وان الوحدات الاوكرانيه منخرطه
حاليا في عمليات دفاعيه وهجوميه على طول
خط التماس بين الجيشين بحسب نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني حان مليار كثافه الرد
الروسي في دانياتك تبدو واضحه في اتجاه
محور افديافكا استهدفت القوات الروسيه
بقصف مدفعي مكثف مواقع للجيش الاوكراني
ونفذ سلاح الجو غارات على افدي افكا ونوفو
ضخمه
وفي اتجاه محور ماريانكا في دنيات قصف
الجيش الروسي عددا من نقاط تتمركز فيها
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تمكنت من احراز
تقدم ميداني بنحو كيلومتر واحد في مقاطعه
اجريدار رغم استمرار الاستهداف الروسي
ذابولوجيا وخيرسون ايضا تعرضتان لقصف روسي
بحسب ما افادت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ونبقى في الجبهه الجنوبيه حيث قالت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في اوديسا ان
الدفاعات الجويه تعاملت مع هجوم جوي
بمسيرات مفخخه وصواريخ كروز
الوضع عند الجبهه الشرقيه لا يختلف كثيرا
اكثر من منطقه في بخموت تعرضت لقصف مدفعي
ترافق ايضا مع غارات لمقاتلات روسيه وتظهر
صور من محور بخموت نشرها الجيش الاوكراني
ان الطرفين يخوضان قتالا مباشرا وعلى وقع
توسيع رقعه الرد الروسي على الهجمات
الاوكرانيه المضاده رحب الامين العام
للنيتو يعني
بقرار بعض من دول الحلف تدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على استخدام مقاتلات لكنه قال
ان من المبكر اتخاذ قرار بشان تسليم
الطائرات واعتبر ان المكاسب الاوكرانيه
على الارض ستلعب لصالح كييف عند الوصول
الى مرحله المفاوضات المحتمله لانهاء
الحرب
[موسيقى]
نقلت شبكه سي ان ان عن نائب رئيس الاركان
العامه الاوكرانيه تاكيده استعاده السيطره
على اكثر من مئه كيلومتر مربع من الاراضي
في اتجاه زابولوجيا خلال الاسبوع الماضي
وقال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
مميزا وقدرات كبيره للجيش الاوكراني في
حرب ضد روسيا وفي مؤتمر صحفي مشترك مع
رئيس هيئه الاركان مارك ميلي في مقر حلف
الناتو بروكسل اضاف الوزير الامريكي ان
اهم اولويات واشنطن حاليا هي توفير
احتياجات اوكرانيا من منظومات الدفاع
الجوي
هذا وافادت صحيفه واشنطن بوست نقلا عن
مسؤول امريكي رفيع ان اداره بايدن مرتاحه
لمقترح الامين العام لحلف الناتو
والذي من شانه ازاله الحواجز امام عضويه
اوكرانيا في الحلف وذكر المصدر الامريكي
ان المقترح لن يحدد اطارا زمنيا لانضمام
اوكرانيا الى النيتو
من جانبها قالت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زا خروفا ان استخدام السلاح
النووي من قبل روسيا ممكن فقط لاغراض
دفاعيه اضافت في مؤتمر صحفي ان انضمام
اوكرانيا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي او تطبيق
ما يعرف بالنموذج الاسرائيلي للتعاون بين
الجانبين لا يمكن ان يساعد في تسويه الوضع
في اوكرانيا
معنا من اوكسفورد فرانك ليدويج كبير
الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه جلوبساك
للدراسات مرحبا بك سيد فرانك اوكرانيا
ايضا تتحدث عن استعاده اكثر من مئه
كيلومتر من اراضيها منذ بدء الهجوم المضاد
كيف يمكن تقييم هذا التقدم
مساء الخير هذا هذه فقط هي البدايه لسلسله
من الحملات الهجوميه ما باستطاعتنا ان
نتاكد منه ان الاوكرانيين لم يقوموا
بادراجي قواتهم الاساسيه او اغلبها وهم
بالتاكيد لما يواجهه
القوات الاساسيه من الجيش الروسي هذه فقط
هجمات اوليه
تهدف بشكل اساسي لتاسيس
مدى قوه الدفاعات الروسيه وخاصه في تلك
الجبهات الطويله الممتده لا نعرف ما هي
اهداف
الاهداف الاوكرانيه لكننا باستطاعتنا ان
نفترض انهما حققوه لحد الان هو امر مرضي
لا يمكننا ان نتوقع المزيد منطقيا وعلينا
ان ننتظر لنرى تطور الامور من المبكر
والسابق لاوانه ان نصل الى استنتاجات ولكن
الان الطرف الروسي يعلن ايضا زياده
الهجمات ردا على هذا الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني كيف
ما المتوقع من هذا التكثيف للهجمات
الروسيه باعتقادك
اعرف اذا ما كانت هذه الهجمات تحصل فعلا
الروس عاده هم يعلن ما يرغبون الاعلان به
اعلان عنه وكذلك الى اوكرانيا ليس هنالك
طرف محايد يمكننا ان يخبرنا بما يحصل في
ساحات القتال لكننا لكن باستطاعتنا ان
نتوقع ان العمليات الهجوميه التقليديه ان
الدفاع
يتضمن هجمات مضاده قد تكون بعضها ناجحه
والبعض الاخر ليس كذلك هذه هي طبيعه هذه
الظروف حيث يكون هنالك قتال مكثف
بالتالي
من الصعب الجزم ما الذي يحصل حقا من
الواضح انه
ايا من هنالك التقدم احرزه كل من الطرفين
لكن من الواضح ايضا ان في مثل هذه المواقف
فان المهاجم هو لديه زمان المبادره وهو
الذي سيضرب في المكان والزمان الذي يختاره
طيب الان الغرب يستعد لارسال الاف القذائف
الى الطرف الاوكراني كيف من شان هذا الامر
ان يغير في المعادله
الاوكرانيين سيستمرون بشعور بالقلق حول
هذا الامر لانه هنالك دفاعات
مضاده للهجمات الجويه وهذه في حقيقه الامر
هي هم يستنفذ كل الصواريخ الموجوده في تلك
الانظمه بالتالي هنالك جهد كبير تقوده
الدول الغربيه فرنسا المملكه المتحده
وبالتاكيد الولايات المتحده هولندا
والنرويج ودول اخرى ايضا من اجل ان تحاول
ان تضمن ان اوكرانيا باستطاعتها ان تقوم
بتم امداد هذه الانظمه واستبدالها في بعض
الحالات من اجل ان تواجه اوكرانيا الهجمات
التي كنتم تعرضونها في الشاشه بمعنى اخر
انهم يقومون بتلبيه طلب الملح من
الاوكرانيين طلب مئات هذه الصواريخ والقذا
فهذه اخبار طيبه للاوكرانيين اذا ما
استطعت هذه الذخيره ان تصلهم في الوقت
المناسب شكرا لك من اوكسفورد فرانك كبير
الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه للدراسات
[موسيقى]
اختتم امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني زياره رسميه الى العراق هي الاولى
لزعيم عربي منذ تشكيل الحكومه الجديده وقد
عقد الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ثاني امير قطر
ورئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني
وبحثات تناولت علاقات البلدين ومجالات
التعاون والقضايا المشتركه واعرب الشيخ
تميم عن عزمي دوله قطر استثمار خمسه
مليارات دولار في عدد من القطاعات في
العراق خلال السنوات القادمه وشهدت
الزياره توقيعا على عدد من الاتفاقيات
ومذكرات التفاهم بين البلدين في مجالات
البنيه التحتيه والسياحه والصحه بهدف
توسيع التعاون الاستثماري والتجاري بين
البلدين
وخلال كلمه بعد لقائه رئيس وزراء العراق
محمد شياع السوداني في بغداد قال امير
دوله قطر ان بلاده ستواصل دعمها للعراق
والشعب العراقي كما اوضح الشيخ تميم بن
حمد ال ثاني انه ناقش مع رئيس الوزراء
العراقي التطورات في المنطقه وتم تاكيد
على تغيب لغه الحوار
تعتزم دوله قطر مواصاه البحث عن الفرص
الاستثماريه المتاحه في العراق لتعزيز
التعاون الاقتصادي بين البلدين ندرك اهميه
العراق ودوره في المنطقه ونؤمن بان امن
العراق واستقراره هو من امن وامن واستقرار
المنطقه ونؤكد باننا سنواصل دعمنا للعراق
وللشعب العراقي الشقيق ومساندته في تحقيق
تطلعاته في تعزيز الامن والتنميه
من جانب قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
شياع السوداني خلال كلمه بعد المباحثات مع
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
قال ان قطر ستبقى واحده من اقوى حلفاء
وشركاء العراق في المنطقه واوضح ان
المحادثات تناولت مجالات مختلفه بينها
التعاون الامني والمعلوماتي مما يصب في
الحفاظ على الامن المشتركي والاقليمي
تبقى اليوم المقاربه
لحكومتنا مقارب الاساسيه هي اقتصاديه
والتركيز على ربط المصالح
والترابط في البنى التحتيه والاستثمارات
المتبادله مع اشقائنا وشركائنا الاقليبيين
والدوليين ودوله قطر ستبقى واحده من اقوى
حلفائنا وشركائنا في المنطقه
هذا وقال امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
ال ثاني في تغريده على تويتر انه اجرى
اليوم وبحثات مع رئيس الوزراء وزراء
العراق محمد شياع السوداني حول سبل تطوير
التعاون بين البلدين اضافه الى القضايا
الاقليميه والدوليه ذات الاهتمام المشترك
كما اكد امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني دعم بلاده لوحده العراق واستقراره
واستعادته لدوره الهام في المنطقه والعالم
كما قال امير دوله قطر انه يشكر الاشقاء
في بغداد على الحفاوه والتكريم
وقال باسم العوادي المتحدث باسم الحكومه
العراقيه في مقابله مع الجزيره ان مذكرات
التفاهم والاتفاقيات التي وقعت ستنقل
العلاقات بين قطر والعراق الى مستوى
استراتيجي اضاف ان العراق يقدر سعي قطر
لتحقيق الاستقرار في المنطقه
قطر يعني لديها مواقف جيده او ممتازه مع
العراق نحن نحتفظ لقطر بمجموعه من
الايجابيات الكثيره خلال السنوات الماضيه
لم تكن قطر بعيده عن العراق من ناحيه دعم
العراق الوقوف مع العمليه السياسيه تبادل
الزيارات تبادل اللقاءات لكنها لم تتحول
الى علاقات اقتصاديه استثماريه علاقات
فعلا تشبك مصالح البلدين بصوره حقيقيه جدا
طبعا نقدر عاليا دائما وباستمرار سعي قطر
الى الاستقرار في المنطقه البحث عن
الاستقرار الوساطات التي تقوم بها قطار
حراكها على مختلف الدول الفاعله في
المنطقه تحاول ان تستوعب المشاكل كثيرا
[موسيقى]
وقال جابر الحرمي رئيس تحرير جريده الشرق
القطريه في مقابله مع الجزيره ان زياره
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
تحمل في طياتها العديد من الرسائل ليس فقط
على المستوى الثنائي وانما على مستوى
الاقليم
هناك فرص متعدده في لدى الجانبين الجانب
العراقي والجانب القطري حجم الاتفاقيات
وحجم الاستثمار وما اعلن عنه عن
مشاريع في مجال الطاقه الربط الكهربائي
السكك الحديد وغيرها من هذه المشاريع سوف
تنعش المنطقه وسوف تدفع بضخ مليارات من
اجل التنميه وهذا ما تحتاجه اليوم المنطقه
ربما جربنا طوال عقود اربعه من صراع من
استنزاف من طاقات مهدره انا الاوان ان
نتجه الى هذا الى هذا الخيار وان يكون هذا
هو الخيار الاستراتيجي
[موسيقى]
على وقعي توتر متزايدا في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه سقط صاروخان بالستيان اطلقتهما
كوريا الشماليه في المنطقه الاقتصاديه
البحريه الخالصه لليابان واعتبرت سول
وتوكيو الحادثه استفزازا وانتهاكا لقرارات
الامم المتحده تاتي التجربه الصاروخيه في
اعقاب اجراء القوات الكوريه الجنوبيه
والقوات الامريكيه تدريبات مشتركه
بالذخيره الحيه في منطقه شمال شرقي
العاصمه سول
مزيد من رسائل القوه في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه اخرها كان صاروخيا من بيونغيانج
الى خصومها فاستمرارا لسلسله تجاربها
اطلقت كوريا الشماليه صاروخين باليستيين
قصيري المدى سقط في بحر اليابان جيش كوريا
الجنوبيه قال انه رصد عمليه الاطلاق مساء
الخميس من منطقه سونان نحو البحر الشرقي
واكد حاله التاهب بالتنسيق الوثيق مع
الولايات المتحده معتبرا الحادث استفزازا
خطيرا ينتهك عقوبات الامم المتحده
وفي طوكيو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع سقوط
الصاروخين فالمنطقه البحريه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه لليابان التي تمتد الى نحو 200
ميل بحري من ساحل البلاد خارج حدود مياهها
الاقليميه وقد شجب رئيس الحكومه التجربه
الصاروخيه الجديده
اليوم اطلقت كوريا الشماليه عده صواريخ
باليستيه سقطت في منطقتنا الاقتصاديه
الخالصه حادث اليوم يتعارض مع قرار مجلس
الامن الدولي وهو عمل من اعمال العنف
يساعد الاستفزاز وقد احتجنا بشده على
كوريا الشماليه جاءت هذه التطورات بعد
ساعات من انهاء الجيشين الامريكي والكوري
الجنوبي تدريبات مشتركه بالذخيره الحيه
عند الخطوط الاماميه بمحاذاه الجاره
الشماليه المناورات التي اشرف عليها رئيس
كوريا الجنوبيه شارك فيها اكثر من 2500 جن
دي ومقاتلات اف 35 واف سته عشر واثارت هذه
التدريبات السياب يونجيان التي تعتبرها
تمرينات على غزوها واسقاط نظامها السياسي
وقد اكد متحدث عسكري استعداد الجيش
وجاهزيته للتصدي للاستفزازات الاعداء على
حد قوله
ولا تبدا كوريا الشماليه تنفذ تجارب على
مختلف الاسلحه استعدادا للاسوء واتساقا مع
السياسه الدفاعيه التي اعلنها زعيمها قبل
اشهر وفي صميمها الردع النووي
وقال البيت الابيض ان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي عقد في طوكيو اجتماعا مع نظريه
الياباني والكوري الجنوبي لتعزيز الشراكه
الثلاثيه بين هذه الاطراف واوضح بيان
البيت الابيض ان الاجتماع الثلاثي بحث
البرامج النوويه والصاروخيه غير المشروعه
لكوريا الشماليه واخر الاستفزازات وفق
البيان
[موسيقى]
اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده والجزائر تطوران التعاون بين
البلدين في مجال الطاقه بنجاح وقال بوتين
في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظيره الجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون في موسكو ان هناك شركات روسيه
كبيره تعمل في مجال الطاقه بالجزائر
النظر الى العمل في مجال الطاقه ساتحدث عن
هذا لاحقا الا انه يحمل طابعا جدا
روسيا دول
تان نفط والغاز روسيا والجزائر تطوران
التعاون في مجال الطاقه بنجاح في الجزائر
شركات طاقه روسيه كبيره كشركه
التي تعمل بالتعاون مع سنطرات الجزائريه
في حقل العسل شرق الصحراء الجزائريه هناك
ايضا شركه لديها مشاريعه جيده وغيرها من
الشركه
من جانبها اعلن الرئيس والجزائري عبد
المجيد تبون ان بلاده تريد التسريع في
الدخول بمنطقه بريكس حتى تدخل في نظام اخر
غير الدولار الامريكي واليورو
اكبر نقاط فيما يخص الوضع
الدولي
مضطرب جدا
والريدا نريد التعجيل في دخولنا في منظمه
البريكس حتى ندخل في تنظيم اخر غير
الدولار وغير
من موسكو تنضم الينا الينا الباحثه
والمحلله السياسيه مرحبا بك سيده الينا ما
اهميه هذا التقارب بين روسيا والجزائر
بالنسبه لروسيا في هذا التوقيت
[موسيقى]
ولكن الى اي مدى التقارب مع دول مثل
الجزائر يعوض لروسيا كل هذا التدهور
الهائل في العلاقه مع الغرب
والان ليس حديث عن عن التعويض لانه اصلا
الاقتصاد الروسي لما يتاثر كثيرا بسبب
الضغوطات الغربيه هم كانوا يعتقدون انه
التاثير سيكون اكثر ولكن هذا الشيء لم
يحدث وهدف فضلا لعمل البنك المركزي الروسي
وفضلا يمكن للدراسات سابقه لانه كما يبدو
روسيا كانت تتوقع مثل هذه الضغوطات
والعقوبات
فالان هناك اشياء اكثر من ذلك اكثر من
تعويض لانه هذا التنسيق ما بين روسيا
والجزائر
وياتي في اطار
انتهاء الهيمنه الامريكيه الدوليه فهذا
شيء مهم برايي لانه الان مثلا الجزائر
تريد دخول في منظمه بريكس وروسيا ترحب
بهذا الشيء بشده
نظرنا لمنظمه بريكس فهناك الصين هناك
برازيل هناك جنوب افريقيا دول اخرى كما
هناك دول عربيه متعدده تريد العضويه الان
في هذه المنظمه
فهذا يعني انه كثير من الدول تسعه للتنسيق
ما بينها وهذا
رغم الاعتراض الامريكي ورغم الضغوطات
الامريكيه طيب وفي ايضا خلال هذه
المباحثات حديث جزائري عن مبادره
للسلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا ماذا في
تفاصيل ذلك خصوصا وان طرف الروسي رحب بذلك
نعم هناك الحديث حول زياده التعاون
التجاري والاقتصادي وايضا تنسيق في مجال
الطاقه
وشركه الروسيه هي الان تتعاون مع شركه
سوناتراك الجزائريه في مجال التنقيب النفط
والغاز بالاضافه لشركه
وهذا الفعل لشركه الكبيره ايضا هي تريد ان
تستثمر في الجزائر كل هذا مهم جدا خاصه
انه في السابق دول اوروبيه كانت تحاول
اغراء جزائر باساليب مختلفه لكي تشكل
تنافسا لتصدرات الغاز الروسي الى اوروبا
ولكن رغم ذلك هناك تنسيق التنسيق في اطار
منظمه مهمه وهو مؤتمر منتجيه للغاز
الجزائر وروسيا ما بين مؤسسيه هذه المنظمه
وايضا في اطار بلس فكل هذا يدل على ان
هناك حكمه سياسيه واراده سياسيه لكي يتحول
هذا التنافس الممكن لكن
عن الوساطه حتى التي قالت الجزائر انها
تريد القيام بها في بين روسيا واوكرانيا
على كل لم يعد لدينا الوقت لم تجاوبيني
على السؤال شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو الينا
المحلله الباحثه والمحلله السياسيه شكرا
فيما يخص مخرجات القمه الروسيه الجزائريه
سيكون لنا حديث معمق بعد قليل عن تكتل
بريكس الاقتصادي ونشاته واهدافه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت قواته خفر السواحل اليونانيه مصرعه
79 من طالبي اللجوء اثراء غرق مركبهم
قباله السواحل اليونانيه وانقذ خفر
السواحل
واربعه اشخاص في عمليه وصفها بانها واحده
من اكبر عمليات البحث على الاطلاق في
البحر المتوسط بدورها اشاره منظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده الى ان حادث
الغرق يعد واحدا من اكبر الماسي في البحر
المتوسط مشيره الى وجود ما يصل الى 400
شخص علمتني قارب الصيد الغارق في حين قالت
جمعيه حقوقيه اوروبيه انها تلقت من القارب
نداء استغاثه تحدث عن وجود ما لا يقل عن
750 شخصا عالمته
من نيويورك معنى كاسرن مهوني المتحدثه
باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين مرحبا بك سيده كاثرين
بدايه ما اخر معلوماتكم بشان عمليات
الانقاذ اعداد القتلى
هذا حدث صادم وفضيع يستمروا بالحدوث في
البحر المتوسط ليس لدينا معلومات نهائيه
لكن شهادات الناجيني تنص على انه كان
هنالك بين 4700 شخص نعرف انه ما يصل الى
قد قتل حوالي 80 شخصا والمئات ما يزالون
مفقودين ويخشى انهم قد قتلوا قد انقذ 100
شخص حقيقه الوضع ان الناس سيستمرون بخوض
هذه
الرحلات الخطيره ما لما نجد حلولا لظروف
القاهره التي تجبر الناس على مغادرتي
اوطانهم وهنا سؤال يعني هذه الكارثه من
المسؤول عنها
وقع وقع ما اقوله انه هنالك اشخاص علينا
يوم امس ان هنالك
مئه وعشره مليون شخص
يضطرون الى مغادره اوطانهم ومنازلهم بعضهم
يفرون من العنف والظروف الصعبه والعديد
منهم يستمرون بخوض غمار هذه الرحلات
الخطره اذا لم يجدوا طريقه قانونيه وامنه
اذا لم بالتالي هم سيستمرون بالمخاطره
بحياتهم وحياتي اولادهم لانهم لا يشعرون
بالامان في اوطانهم حقيقه ان هذه حالات
الوفيات هذه يمكن منعها وليس هنالك اي
معنى لها بالتالي نحن في وكالتنا يعني هذا
هذا القارب خرج من من مكان كان ذاهبا الى
مكان
في الطريق اتلقى جمعيات نداءات استغاثه
منه كل هذه العناصر
اين كان بالامكان تجنب هذه الكارثه
كل كل هذه الظروف يمكن منعها وبدون اليست
لها اي معنى نحن على وعي ظروف التي ادت
الى هذا الامر لكننا لسنا على تواصل
المعاصر السلطات اليونانيه حولنا التواصل
معهم من اجل الحصول على تفاصيل هذا الحادث
لكن الصوره الاكبر هي ان تلك القوارب
ستستمر بالانطلاق وهؤلاء الاشخاص سيستمرون
بالمخاطره بحياتهم من اجل الوصول الى مكان
امن بالتالي نحن نستمر بدعوه الاتحاد
الاوروبي من اجل ان يزيدوا من اجراءاتهم
في حمايه الاشخاص الذين
يركبون تلك القوارب من نيويورك مهوني
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين شكرا جزيلا لك
بمثل اتساعه وامتداده تبدو ماسيه الحاضره
كل عام تقريبا هذا هو الوجه الاخر لحلم
عبور البحر المتوسط والوصول الى اوروبا
عشرات الغرقان تشلهم خفروا السواحل
اليونانيه من ضحايا حادث وصفته المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده
بانه احد اكبر الماسي التي شهدها هذا
البحر وقد يرتفع عدد الضحايا بالنظر الى
اشاره المنظمه الدوليه وجمعيات حقوقيه
اخرى الى وجود المئات كانوا على متن قارب
قبل غرقه استنادا الى خفر السواحل
اليوناني فان القارب غرق هنا قباله شبه
جزيره بيلوبونيز جنوب غربي اليونان انقذ
حتى الان اكثر من 100 شخص مع استمرار
عمليه البحث التي وصفها خبر السواحل
اليونانيه باحدى اكبر عمليات البحث في
البحر المتوسط اذ تشارك فيها فرقاطه من
البحريه اليونانيه وطائره ومروحيه من سلاح
الجو اضافه الى الزوارق من اين انطلق قارب
المهاجرين غير النظاميين وفق المعلومات
الاوليه فان القاربه بدا رحلته من سواحل
ليبيا التي تشكل مع سواحل تونس ولبنان
وتركيا ابرز اماكن ان طلاق قوارب طالب
اللجوء باتجاه دول جنوبي اوروبا مثل الجزر
اليونانيه وايطاليا اما عن تكرار حوادث
غرق القوارب بمن فيها فتبرز هنا فرضيات
عده منها ما يوصف بجشع شبكات التهريب
وتحميل القوارب المتهلكه اصلا اكثر من
سعتها باضعاف اضافه الى عدم وجود سترات
نجاه او وسائل اتصال لاطلاق نداءات
الاستغاثه حين الحاجه
هذه الصور قيل انها لخفر السواحل اليوناني
اتهم وقتها باطلاق الرصاص على احد قوارب
اللاجئين في بحر ايجا بهدف ابعاده عن
المياه اليونانيه هذا وتواجه عواصم
اوروبيه اتهامات من منظمات غير حكوميه
ووسائل اعلام بسبب قيام خبر سواحلها
باجراءات الابعاد القصري لطالب اللجوء
واتهامات اخرى مثل استئجارها مجموعات غير
نظاميه تتولى صد محاولات العبور عبر البحر
كما تتهم تلك العواصم بانها لا تحرك ساكنا
الا بعد ضغوط من منظمات حقوقيه وانسانيه
غير حكوميه لدفعها الى مد طوق النجاه
وانقاذ من يمكن انقاذه من المهاجرين غير
النظاميين القادمين عبر البحر
نعود الى السعي الجزائري للدخول تحت مظله
مجموعه بريكس ياتي هذا في توقيت تتعالى
فيه اصوات من اجل عالم متعدد الاقطاب ومنذ
انشنت روسيا حربها على اوكرانيا بدات تكتل
بريكس الاقتصاديه ياخذ ابعادا جيوسياسيه
في البدايه كان اسمها بريك وهي الاحرف
الاولى باللاتينيه لدول الاعضاء منذ
التاسيس عام 2006 وهي البرازيل وروسيا
والهند والصين وتتميز الدول الاعضاء بانها
من الدول الناميه الصناعيه التي تتمتع
باقتصادات كبيره وصاعده وعقدت اول مؤتمر
لها في مدينه ياكاترين برجر روسيه عام
2009 في 2010 وبعد انضمام جنوب افريقيا
الى المجموعه صار اسمها بريكس في عام 2014
دشنت مجموعه بري بنك التنميه الجديد براس
مال ابتدائي قدره 50 مليار دولار كبديلا
للبنك وصندوق النقد الدوليين وفي مارس
الماضي كشفت جنوب افريقيا عن تلقي اثنتي
عشره رساله من دول ابدت رغبتها في التعامل
مع المجموعه ومن ضمنها السعوديه والامارات
ومصر والجزائر والارجنتين والمكسيك
ونيجيريا
ليس منتدى البريكس فريدا من نوعه بالطبع
فهناك تكتلات دوليه مشابهه لعل من اهمها
تكتل جي 7 وهو تكتل من سبع دول من اقوى
اقتصادات العالم وكانت روسيا عضوا فيه لكن
عضويتها الغيت احتجاجا على احتلالها
لجزيره القرد يتالف التكتل من فرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا والولايات المتحده
وكندا وايطاليا واليابان مجموعه التنميه
لدول جنوب افريقيا وهي مؤلفه من تسع دول
من اهمها جنوب افريقيا وانجولا وزامبيا
اما رابطه اسيان فيا رابطه لدول جنوب شرق
اسيا وهي اتحاد سياسي اقتصادي بين عشره
اعضاء اما المجموعه الكارديه كاريكوم فذات
صبغه تعاونيه سياسيه واقتصاديه وتضم خمسه
عشره دوله من الامريكيتين والكاريبي وهنا
ايضا مجموعه العشرين وهي تكتل مؤلف من 20
دوله من اقوى الاقتصادات ويحتكر التكتل
75% من التجاره العالميه واخيرا هناك تكتل
السوق الجنوبي المشتركه ميركوسور هو تكتل
اقتصادي في امريكا اللاتينيه ويضم دولا من
اهمها البرازيل وباراغواي وتشيلي
والاكوادور وبيرو ينضم الينا حول هذا
الموضوع من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني
استاذ العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
في جامعه جونز مرحبا بك دكتور خليل ما
المميزات والمكتسبات التي تحصل عليها
الدول في حال انضمامها الى مثل هذه
المجموعات لا سيما هنا نتحدث عن مجموعه
البريكس
نحن نتحدث عن واحد من اكبر التجمعات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه في العالم حوالي 24%
من حجم صدر العالمي مع دول بريكس حارس
التجاره الدوليه اربعين سكان العالم في
هذه الدول بتتكلم عن دولتين كبيرتين
كالصين روسيا معهما دولتين اخريين
البرازيل والهند ثم جنوب افريقيا دول
كبيره ومؤثره ثم تسمى
الناشئه وبالتالي انضمام الى هذه الدول
تعتبر قوه سياسيه واقتصاديه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالحديث حاليا حول انشاء مؤسسات
اقتصاديه قد تحل بشكل او باخر محل ما يطلق
عليه اجماع واشنطن او واشنطن
فيما يتعلق بنظام برايتون وودز والذي يضم
البنك الدولي صندوق النقد الدولي ايضا
هناك حديث حول احتمال لجوء او انشاء عمله
خاصه بهذه المجموعه بالتالي محاوله
للانفكاك بشكل او اخر من هيمنه الدولار
باعتباره للعمله المهيمنه على صدر على
فوائد كثيره جدا
هذا المسعى من جانب البريكس لطرح عمله
موحده على ماذا يستند والى اي مدى هو
واقعي باعتقادك
يستند اولا على القوه الاقتصاديه لهذه
البلدان تتحدث عن الصين استمتعتبر الثاني
دولار ايضا دوله اقتصاديه مهمه جدا خاصه
فيما يتعلق بالنفط والطاقه وحجمها
الجغرافي ايضا الهند تمثل دوله مهمه جدا
اقتصاديا استراتيجيا وسياسيا كذلك
البرازيل ومعهما افريقيا وبالتالي هناك
قوه اقتصاديه لا باس بها كما قلت قبل قليل
العالمي في هذه المنطقه من العالم الامر
الثاني مدى واقعيه ذلك قد يبدو الامر
حاليا غير واقعي خاصه في ظل هيمنه العليا
للدولار وفي ظل ايضا وجود ارتباط او
اعتماد دوله عليه لكن شكلها باخر نجد او
نلاحظ مؤخرا ان هناك محاوله فك الارتباط
هذا هناك نجاح قد يكون نسبي بشكل او باخر
فيما يتعلق باستخدام البترو ايوان او
استخدام الصين العملات فيما يتعلق
بالتبادات النفطيه بعض الدول الخاصه
السعوديه او الدول او مثل او ايران او الى
ذلك وبالتالي هناك امكانيه للنجاح
المستقبل في المستقبل المتوسط او طويل
المدى على الاقل الدكتور خليل كيف تنظر
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي الى
هذا التطور الذي يشهده البريكس يعني من
جهه هناك طلب لعضويه كامله وهناك طلبات
ايضا لتعاون معمق لاسيما من دول تعتبر
تاريخيا حليفه للولايات المتحده والغرب
هذا صحيح الى حد بعيد هناك حاله تحسب
وتحسن لهذه المساله هناك قناعه بان هناك
عمليه تحول في نظام الدولي خاصه بعد حرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا هناك عمليه اعاده
تموضع استراتيجي على مستوى العالم هناك
رغبه للدول التي تنضوي تحت
الارتباط الاعتبارها دوله عالميه مهيمنه
كتحسب امريكي خاصه في ظل وجود توسع للنفوذ
الصيني وروسيا في افريقيا ووجود علاقات
روسيه جزائريه تمثل بالفعل نقطه قلق
لامريكا ولذلك كانت هناك محاولات امريكيه
للضغط على الجزائر من اجل ان تكون في
شراكه اقتصاديه وسياسيه مع روسيا ولكن
طبعا هذا لم يتم الاتفاق عليه ايضا هناك
مخاوف اوروبيه من يؤدي التعاون الروسي
الجزائري الى تقويه روسيا فيما يتعلق في
اوكرانيا ولذلك هناك ربما ضغوط اوروبيه
على الجزائر حتى تقلل التعاون مع روسيا
بهذا الاطار اشكرك جزيل الشكر من واشنطن
الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ العلوم
السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه
في جامعه جونز هوبكنز
مشاهدينا الكرام بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه حصاد هذه الليله شكرا لمتابع